ja was in dieser
Legislaturperiode uns alle erwartet ihr
habt gerade die Grünen angesprochen es
wollen wir uns mit einem Post Ansehen
einer jungen grünen Abgeordneten wir
schauen hier einmal rein es ging um die
Bänder die man tragen musste heute im
Bundestag Tag und das hier bei Instagram
hat die junge grüne Politikerin aus Gera
aus Thüringen
noch als Georg gegen zu viele
Nationalflaggen argumentiert jetzt musst
du das hässlichste Festivalbändchen
aller Zeiten tragen aber zeigt an dass
man 2G ist und deshalb kann ich
ausnahmsweise damit leben
hässlichste Festivalbändchen
große Aufregung auch im Netz über diesen
Post ja das ist einfach ein bizarrer
Einstand als Bundestagsabgeordnete also
sie sitzt im Deutschen Bundestag der
befindet sich im Reichstagsgebäude über
dem Reichstagsgebäude steht dem
deutschen Volk und dieses Volk hat sich
nun mal eine Flagge gegeben diese Flagge
steht in Deutschland für Demokratie das
ist keine Flagge der Diktatur oder sonst
was diese Flagge steht für die deutschen
Institutionen auch die garantieren dass
wir in einer Demokratie und in einem
Rechtsstaat leben auch für den Deutschen
Bundestag was man das nicht jeder gleich
patriotisch ist dass manche Menschen in
Deutschland auch deutsche natürlich ein
gewissen inneren Zwiespalt haben beim
Thema Patriotismus auch angesichts der
deutschen Geschichte ist ja völlig klar
aber dass man diese Flaggen als
hässlichste aller Zeiten bezeichnet das
verstehe ich nicht gibt es irgendeinen
anderen Staat in dem dem Frau piota
vielleicht lieber im parlam sitzen würde
und wenn man schon sagt dass hässlichste
Bändchen aller Zeiten was ist denn mit
den ganzen Diktaturen die findet Frau
picota weniger schlimm ich frage mich
wenn man die Flagge so sehr ablehnt
lehnt man auch die Institutionen dann ab
sie gehört ja nun eine zentralen
Institution an also ich glaube da haben
die Grünen noch wirklich Klärungsbedarf
und man muss aber auch sagen sie gibt
nicht wieder was alle in der grünen
Fraktion denken Cem Özdemir hat vor
einigen Jahren sich ganz klar bekannt zu
deutschen Flagge hat gesagt das ist eine
Flagge der Vielfalt das ist eine Flagge
der Demokratie und selbstverständlich
ist er nicht bereit diese Flagge
irgendwelchen Rechtsextremen zu
überlassen aber genau das tut Frau
piechotter wenn sie heute in ihrem
ersten richtigen Tag im Bundestag
natürlich so etwas in die Welt Posten in
der künftigen Regierungsfraktion auch
das wird nochmal spannend sein wie die
Grünen dann damit umgehen mit solchen
Diskussionen auch innerhalb der eigenen
Fraktion mit all den Jungen Grünen die
damit eingerückt sind heute den Eindruck
gewinnen sie wär lieber beim
klassenburry Festival heute gewesen nach
dem Bundestag vielleicht möchtest du
vielleicht ist es so